[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo ihr Lieben hier ist eure Toni und
hier ist Mirko bevor es losgeht wollten
wir uns gern bei euch bedanken für die
vielen tollen Bewertungen und
Nachrichten die wir bekommen haben unter
anderem bei Instagram also schaut doch
gern mal vorbei vielen Dank auch für die
vielen fallvorschläge die uns geschickt
habt stellvertretend gehen dabei Grüße
raus an Lisa Sabrina Daniel Maria und
Janina vielen Dank an Euch heute haben
wir wieder einen rätselhaften Fall für
euch einen Cold Case vielleicht kann
dieser Podcast ja auch helfen einen
Mörder zu finden denn das ganze ist im
Vergleich zu anderen Fällen noch nicht
so lange her
[Musik]
es ist die Nacht vom 4 auf den fünften
april 2012 wir befinden uns in
Berlin-Neukölln einem Stadtteil der
bundesweit immer wieder Schlagzeilen
macht als Problemviertel fünf junge
Männer sind auf der Rudower Straße
unterwegs sie haben sich getroffen um
sich zu unterhalten zu rauchen und etwas
zu trinken an der Bushaltestelle
Möwenweg bleiben sie stehen Rauchen eine
letzte Zigarette bevor sich dann die
Jungs auf den Heimweg machen wollen was
dann passiert schildern zwei von ihnen
selbst Markus und öhner im Kreis haben
uns unterhalten ganz normal hatte ich
ein bisschen die Gruppe getrennt so
jeder hatte seine eigenen Gespräche und
ja dann habe ich gemerkt dass einer
kommt und dann hat er einfach seine
Waffe gezogen hat geschossen auf uns
mehrmals dann hat er zuerst glaube ich
Markus getroffen
ist sind wir losgerannt auf die Straße
dann habe ich gemerkt dass nur
auf der Straße runter zu ihm und äh war
ja schon gut überstimmt lag auf dem
Boden Markus und Alex lang auf dem
Bürgersteig und als ich mich zu dem Mann
gedreht habe stand dann noch da hat mit
seiner Waffe rum gespielt dann hat er
sich irgendwann umgedreht das einfach
davon gelaufen mindestens vier Schüsse
sind gefallen drei der fünf Freunde
werden getroffen Alex Markus den wir
eben gehört haben und Burak Alex und
Markus überleben den Vorfall nur dank
Notoperationen aber Burak Bektas der
überlebt nicht der lungendurchschuss ist
tödlich der Vater von Burak ist in den
80er Jahren aus der Türkei nach Berlin
gekommen und hat hier seine Frau
kennengelernt das Paar hat insgesamt
drei Kinder Burak wird 1990 geboren er
macht den Realschulabschluss und
absolviert eine Ausbildung zum
Automobilkaufmann seine große
Leidenschaft sind Autos schon als Kind
hat er seiner Mutter die
unterschiedlichen Automarken erklärt
im April 2012 arbeitet er bei einer
Berliner Fiat Filiale und dann die
Schüsse aus dem Nichts zwei verletzt
einer tot was ist hier passiert der Fall
stellt die Öffentlichkeit und die
Polizei vor ein großes Rätsel Schüsse in
Neukölln junge Männer mit
Migrationshintergrund da bieten sich
leider jede Menge Klischees und
Vorurteile an um Vermutungen zum Fall zu
äußern aber nichts davon trifft zu den
Schüssen ist weder ein Streit
vorausgegangen noch führen Spuren des
Geschehens zu Banken kämpfen oder der
organisierten Kriminalität
es ging nicht um Drogen oder Rivalität
um Frauen jemand hat einfach so wie aus
dem Nichts auf normale junge Leute
geschossen und einen von ihnen getötet
das zeigt übrigens wie unsinnig all die
genannten Vorurteile sind und die
Ermittlungen brachte es auch nicht
weiter denn auch die Überlegung des
Rassismus im Spiel gewesen sein könnte
ergibt erstmal keine heiße Spur
jedenfalls nicht unmittelbar nach der
Tat erst drei Jahre später passiert
etwas in Berlin-Neukölln das im
Zusammenhang mit dem Tod von Burat
Bektas stehen könnte und zwar der Fall
Luke Holland das war ein 31 Jahre alter
Engländer der 2015 an einer Neuköllner
ringbahnstraße erschossen wurde auch
hier feuerte jemand ohne erkennbare
Vorgeschichte auf einen jungen Mann und
auch hier hatte das Opfer einen
Migrationshintergrund aber der Fall
konnte aufgeklärt werden Holland ist mit
bekannten auf Kneipentour kurz vor 6 Uhr
am Morgen des 20 September 2015 ist er
in der Bar Dell Rex und erhält einen
Anruf aus England er geht vor die Tür
und telefoniert kurz darauf wird der
erschossen Zeugen haben zwar nicht den
Schuss erlebt aber sie haben den Täter
gesehen und helfen so entscheidend bei
den Ermittlungen denn die Beschreibung
der Zeugen passt zu einem Gast der das
direkt zuvor verlassen hat es war der
damals 63 Jahre alte Rolf Z weil man bei
ihm Nazi-Symbole wie eine hitler-büste
fand wurde eine ausländerfeindliche Tat
vermutet aber das ließ sich im Prozess
gegen Zecken nicht erhärten obwohl die
Verteidigung argumentiert Z sei bei der
Tat im voll raus gewesen und deshalb
nicht wirklich schuldfähig wird er zu
elf Jahren und 7 Monaten Haft verurteilt
aber auch 2015 lässt sich mit diesen
Spuren der Fall Burak Taschen nicht
aufklären und auch als ich dessen Tod
2022 zum 10 mal lehrt ist der Mord noch
ungesund
an diesem traurigen Jahrestag trifft
bildreporterin Lena Zander den Anwalt
der Familie und nur ösata wir wissen
dass es einen Mann gewesen sein muss der
über 50 war so beschreiben es alle
Opfer und Zeugen wir wissen dass er eine
Kapuzenjacke anhatte und dass er äußerst
ruhig agiert hat also das war jemand der
sehr gezielt auf diese Gruppe
Zulieferung und die Tat sehr gezielt
ausgeführt hat wir wissen aber auch
nicht mehr er hat ja nicht mal was
gesagt als er geschossen hat nur und nur
öser tat der Anwalt der Familie Becker
erkennt als erster die Parallelen zum
fallend er bringt auch wieder ein
mögliches rechtsextremes Motiv ins Spiel
ösata fordert die Polizei auf dem
nachzugehen doch es passiert nicht der
Anwalt wirft in Ermittlungsbehörden vor
ein rechtsextremes Motiv nicht
ausreichend untersucht zu haben die
Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft weiß diese
Vorwürfe zurück
wir ermitteln in alle Richtungen sagt
Sprecher Dieter Horstmann gegenüber Bild
am Sonntag ein rechtes Tatmotiv sei
überprüft worden und können nicht
ausgeschlossen werden aber es ließe sich
auch nicht beliegen inzwischen wird auch
Rolf zetzum Tod von Burak Bektas
vernommen er sagt im Januar 2022 als
Zeuge aus laut dem Berliner Staatsanwalt
Martin glaage bestreitet er die Tat und
auch von den bei Z gefundenen Waffen
stimmt keine mit der Tatwaffe im Fall
Burak Bektas überein eine weitere Spur
verläuft ebenfalls im Sand kurz nach der
Tat heißt es das Motiv könne im
persönlichen Bereich liegen ein
Bekannter sagt der Polizei Burak sei bei
Mädchen immer gut angekommen kurz vor
der Tat soll er auf unschöne Weise mit
einer ebenfalls türkischstämmigen
Freundin schluss gemacht haben wollte
also jemand Rache an Burak nehmen die
Aussage bringt dir Ermittlungen nicht
weiter Freunde der Familie und
engagierte Leute in Neukölln kümmern
sich darum Burak nicht vergessen wird
auf der Rudower Straße Höhe Hausnummer
51 unweit der Bushaltestelle Möwenweg
steht seit 2018 ein Denkmal und zwar
eine etwa zwei Meter hohe abstrakte
Bronzeskulptur auf einer Tafel daneben
steht an diesem Ort wurde am 5 April
2012 borag Bektas von einem Unbekannten
ermordet der wortlos in eine Gruppe
jugendlich erschoss außerdem ist am
Gedenkort eine rote Basecap abgelegt die
mittlerweile verblasst solche roten Caps
waren buraks Markenzeichen sein bester
Freund Ömer denkt bis heute ständig an
die tödliche Nacht gesagt es fühlt sich
an als wäre es erst letzte Woche
passiert manchmal besucht der Borax
Mutter sie wird jedes mal traurig wenn
sie ihn sieht und fängt an zu weinen für
Mutter Melek Bektas steht seit dem Tod
ihres Sohnes die Zeit still zu Bild sagt
sie manchmal sitze ich auf der Treppe in
unserem Haus und sehe wie Bora kommt die
rote Cap auf dem Kopf aber er wird nie
wiederkommen
und an dieser Stelle haben wir heute ein
bisschen was besonderes für euch Lena
Zander ist jetzt bei uns hallo schön
dass du da bist ja ich freue mich dass
ich bei euch sein kann du hast diesen
Fall ja intensiv verfolgt zum Beispiel
auch den Anwalt der Familie getroffen
als Reporterin da hast du ja jeden Tag
mit schrecklichen Verbrechen zu tun also
du kannst ihm ja gar nicht entkommen was
macht diesen Fall für dich so besonders
in dieser Masse an schrecklichen Dingen
die du erlebst warum lässt dieser Fall
dich nach all diesen Jahren nicht mehr
los das Besondere an diesem Fall ist
dass der Täter aus dem Nichts gekommen
ist man muss sich das mal vorstellen da
sind fünf junge Männer unterwegs machen
gar nichts rauchende Abschied Zigarette
an einer Bushaltestelle stehen da noch
und dann kommt er auf einmal jemand
schwarzer Kapuzenpulli zielt auf die
Jungs und schießt war los um sich und
dabei trifft er auch noch drei der Jungs
und einer stirbt und das ist auch das
was mich so besonders bewegt hat und was
nämlich auch ja diesen Fall schwer
loslassen lässt weil das dachte Markus
auch sehr eindringlich es ist so
wahnsinnig erschreckend wenn man sich
vorstellt der Täter kann einer
Supermarktkasse hinter den Jungen stehen
die er zum Teil fast tödlich verletzt
hat und der Täter weiß so sehen die
Opfer aus das habe ich den angetan aber
die Jungs wissen nicht dass es der Mann
der auf uns geschossen hat wahnsinnig
erdrückendes wahnsinnig schlimmes Gefühl
mit dem die Jungs bis heute leben müssen
es steht ja auch im Raum dass da ein
rechtsextremer Hintergrund hinter dieser
Tat eben steckt was glaubst du denn ist
da passiert hast du eine Theorie ich mag
mich denn nicht so weit aus dem Fenster
lernen sondern Rechtsextremismus Motiv
anzunehmen halte ich für ja es ist
möglich aber ich kann nicht definitiv
sagen deshalb ist es passiert ich habe
auch lange mit dem Anwalt der Familie
von Burak gesprochen das ist ohne
Ursacher der sich dem Fall angenommen
hat die mir auch als erstes die
Parallelen aufgefallen sind zu dem Fall
Luke Holland den er vorhin auch schon
angesprochen hattet wo es ja auch so
gewesen ist dass Täter und Opfer vorher
keine Beziehung hatten zueinander wo die
Schüsse auch im ersten Moment zumindest
wie aus dem Nichts gekommen sind und bei
dem Täter wurden ja auch Rechtsextreme
Symbole gefunden in der Wohnung es war
wirklich so dass man sagen kann okay der
hatte einen ich sag das jetzt mal und
charmant eine liebevolle Affinität zu
allem was mit dem rechtsextrem in
Verbindung steht und Herr über hat ja
auch erst die Verbindung hergestellt es
könnte sein dass der Täter der Luke
Holland erschossen hat auch der Täter
ist der Burak Bektas erschossen hat dem
ist es aufgefallen und was bei dem Fall
noch wahnsinnig bemerkenswert ist dass
ich ein Zeuge auch im Fall Burak weck
das bei der Polizei gemeldet hat und
ausgesagt hat das Rolf Zett in
unmittelbarer Nachbarschaft des Tatort
ist ein Bruder gehabt hat zudem er
gefahren sein soll und auch erzählt
haben sollte das
komplett dort damit geprahlt habe
Schießübung im Keller zu machen und wenn
man sich das mal vorstellt da ist jemand
der ein Bezug zum Tatort hat Schießübung
macht vielleicht rechtes Gedankengut in
sich trägt dann wäre das zumindest eine
erklärbare Möglichkeit aber ist denn der
Rolf Z vor diesen zwei Morden schon im
Vorfeld aufgefallen mit ähnlichen Taten
oder tatversuchen Nein Rolf Z war vorher
nicht in Erscheinung getreten wenn es um
Tötungsdelikte oder ähnliches gegen ob
er vielleicht andere
Ordnungswidrigkeiten oder ich sage jetzt
mal Kleinkriminelle Dinge angestellt hat
das kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen aber
es ist zumindest bei rolfz das erste Mal
gewesen dass er vor Gericht gestanden
hat und verurteilt wurde weil er auf
jemanden geschossen hat und in diesem
Fall lokalend auch getötet hat es lange
aber eher so ein bisschen kleiner
untertun dass die Polizei über den
Ermittlungen dann vielleicht ein
bisschen nachlässig war bzw sogar fast
geschlampt hat naja man stellt sich ja
schon die Frage haben sich so ein Zeuge
bei der Polizei meldet und sagt Mensch
der ist jemand in unmittelbarer Nähe des
Tatorts und der hat Schießübungen im
Keller gemacht der hat jemanden
nachweislich des Urteil gegen lokalen
das gab es ja auch erschossen da fragt
man sich schon okay als Außenstehender
warum wurde nicht weiter in diese
Richtung ermittelt warum verlief diese
Spur im Sande das ist ganz klar das ist
ja auch erst fast zehn Jahre nach der
Tat passiert dass Rolf zu diesem Fall
befragt wurde die Staatsanwaltschaft hat
ja auch wirklich viele Jahre vergehen
lassen nach Borax tot um ihn dann auch
zu dieser Tat zu befragen fragt man sich
schon warum ohne Isetta ist da ja auch
der Ansicht dass die Justiz auf dem
rechten Auge ein wenig blind sei er sagt
das sei kein Zufall es natürlich eine
gewagte These aber eine Möglichkeit was
ich sagen muss was mir so ein bisschen
Gänsehaut fast geht der mögliche Täter
also bzw ein Verdächtiger rolfz hat
einen Bezug zum Tatort bei seinem Bruder
ganz in der Nähe wohnt
die Familie von Burak wohnt ja aber auch
ganz in der Nähe des Tatortes wie geht
es denn der Familie von Burak damit da
täglich eigentlich fast dran erinnert zu
werden das ist natürlich ein Thema was
mich auch wahnsinnig bewegt hat ich war
bei Melek bektash das ist die Mutter von
Burak zu Hause ich war in dem Haus in
dem Burak gelebt hat das Kinderzimmer
von Burak war unverändert die Familie
hat nichts daran verändert was mich auch
sehr bewegt hat war als Melek zu mir
sagte ich weiß ich muss vielleicht was
ändern ich weiß ich muss mein Sohn
loslassen aber ich kann ihn nicht
loslassen denn so lange ich alles
unverändert lasse so lange er in
Gedanken noch so bei mir ist und das
Kinderzimmer auch noch so aus wie es
jetzt gerade ist so lange ist er
irgendwie noch bei mir das hat mich
wahnsinnig bewegt und natürlich der
Tatort ist auch unweit des Hauses in dem
die Familie Becker bis heute lebt und
natürlich läuft man da lang natürlich
wird man täglich daran erinnert direkt
an der Unfallstelle oder am Tatort ist
ja auch dieses Denkmal was ich schon
angesprochen hattet aufgestellt und das
ist ein ganz furchtbares Gefühl ich
meine Rock hat auch noch Geschwister es
ist für die gesamte Familie wirklich
kaum auszuhalten aber es ist deren
Eigenheim das ist deren Haus und das
wollen sie auch nicht verkaufen und auch
nicht aufgeben was man ja irgendwo auch
verstehen kann ja wahnsinnig emotional
und ganz ganz schwierig für die gesamte
Familie was mir noch durch den Kopf geht
ist es kann ja im Podcast schon mal ganz
kurz an dass sie sich eventuell oder das
zumindest Vermutungen auch in die
Richtung gegen dass es sich um eine
Beziehung Tat gehandelt haben könnte die
Frage ist gab es da irgendwie
Ermittlungen die das mal bestätigt haben
oder die türkische sprachige Community
in Berliner Stadtteil hat die eventuell
Dinge bestätigen können oder ist das
ziemlich schnell wieder von der Hand
gewesen worden also die Spur was ein wie
sag ich das am besten Racheakt
vielleicht auch sein könnte die verlief
auch relativ schnell im Sande ich habe
auch mit
darüber gesprochen und Melek sagte auch
naja diese Freundin die gab es gar nicht
so richtig und die Jungs sagten auch na
ja also irgendwie das war auch gar nicht
so was um diese mysteriöse Freundin man
weiß noch nicht mal richtig wann die
überhaupt ein paar ein richtiges Paar
und in welchem Verhältnis standen die
wirklich zueinander da sind auch noch
wahnsinnig viele Fragen offen Burak und
die Freundin Schein gar nichts eng
miteinander gewesen zu sein wie das
vielleicht auf den ersten Blick gewesen
ist also da gibt es nichts was man
irgendwie sagen kann ok dafür eine
Spuren da können wir vielleicht noch mal
nach ermitteln das führt zum Täter also
wirklich im Sande verlaufen weil die
Beziehung zwischen Burak und die Mädchen
auch bis zuletzt nicht genau geklärt
werden konnte also ist das eher
auszuschließen
und wir hoffen natürlich auch wie
anfangs schon erwähnt dass dieser
Podcast vielleicht jemanden ermutigt
noch mal sich bei der Polizei zu melden
wenn er doch irgendwas gesehen hat man
weiß ja nie vielleicht kann der Mörder
noch gefunden werden und wir wollen an
dieser Stelle jetzt nutzen dass du da
bist liebe Lena um noch mal mögliche
Zeugen anzusprechen wer hat in der Nacht
vom 4 auf den 5 April in der Rudower
Straße 51 an der ehemaligen
Bushaltestelle mövenweg wo jetzt ein
Taxistand ist in Berlin-Neukölln etwas
von Schiffen mitbekommen oder vielleicht
sogar einen Mann fliehen sehen es muss
gegen 1:15 Uhr in der Nacht gewesen sein
der Täter trug einen Kapuzenpullover er
soll ca 40 bis 60 Jahre alt gewesen sein
und von normaler Statur der Täter soll
ungefähr 1,70 m bis 1,80 m groß sein wer
hier zu etwas sagen kann oder auch
anderer Hinweise zum Täter hat der melde
sich bitte bei der Berliner Polizei
einen Link und die Telefonnummer gibt es
auch in den Show Notes dieses Podcast
vielen Dank danke liebe Lena schön dass
du da warst und auch danke für deine
Arbeit dass du da so dran bleibst diesen
Fall hast du uns ja vorgeschlagen weil
du gesagt hast Leute mich lässt er nicht
los bitte macht ihn vielen lieben Dank
ja ich danke euch beiden dass ich hier
sein durfte
[Musik]
den Fall haben wir mit deinem Recherchen
liebe Lena erzählt so wie zum Fall New
Holland auch mit zwei Artikeln des
Tagesspiegels gescriptet hat Stefan
Netzeband Aufnahme und schnitt Toni
Heyer Postproduktion in den Weight watch
Studios München das war es für heute wir
danken euch fürs Zuhören euer Mirko und
eure Toni